it's really easy to go down those rabbit
holes
what i've found works best for me and
and
my team members that i've had do things
is make sure that you are constantly
working with business
so that you're not going to down far
down a rabbit hole that they're like i
don't care about that that doesn't
affect me at all
where if i i can get the business
partners
feeling like
it's their project
and they're right beside you like
helping through it
that that decreases the rabbit holes
it's still easy but um i think we all
have a tendency to be like well that's
an interesting problem let's go look at
it but if you have that consistent
relationship with the business person
where you are
are truly working together and it's not
just
okay data scientist go do your thing and
then come back when you're done that's
when i think the rabbit hole problem
gets bad
and there's a tendency for
i think both sides be like well i'm busy
in the business so
you just come back to me later and and
that
as the data scientist i think you just
cannot
you can't go for that like i require if
i'm doing work with you or for you you
have to be my partner
otherwise it's not going to succeed
i don't know if that helps you
but i i have noticed people don't spend
enough time creating that relationship
and enforcing that relationship